every winter millions of people struggle
to heat their homes and the rising cost
of energy just increases the misery SJ
suffers from epilepsy and sight problems
for an example of someone deeply
affected by fuel poverty look no further
than here for years you know I mean I
put it on like half an hour in the
evening but they're storage heaters
there's really not much point I'd put on
another layer and the elderly people I
speak to their thing called reading that
no one will put the heating on at the
moment especially if they over key for
it you know if their therapy or poverty
it's very very hard and it's they're
scary living in assisted housing riddled
with damp a year ago she got into debt
with her energy bills until the charity
turned to us stepped in helping her
navigate the assistance on offer I
didn't know about the hardship funds on
there and that you could get the bill
worked out and be able to move as well
because you can't move unless you've got
your bill cleared turn to us have spoken
to just over 4,000 people over the last
three months 46 percent told them
they've had to cut back on heating to
save money for older people that figure
goes up to 55 percent and over half 53
percent were not aware that energy
suppliers offer support to customers on
low incomes something a meeting in
Westminster later hopes to address
there's a lot of help that exists we
know from our research that we're
releasing today that help doesn't get to
the people who simply struggle who can't
afford to heat their homes over the
winter the purpose of the roundtable
today is to get the big energy providers
together to say right what practically
can we do to get this help to those who
qualify for it with her debts cleared SJ
has switched provider reducing her
weekly bills by a quarter she now hopes
energy companies can promote the help
they offer and ensure other vulnerable
people like her access the support they
need Harriet had failed Sky News sorry